the digital world was a simple world  happy funny cool  but this incredible world with new and  exciting markets and services this is a  world without rules  buying selling  content  photos videos sharing likes data  all of this has become a chaotic world  big and powerful  and we the citizens are stuck in it  [Music]  that is why the digital world needs to  be regulated  the s ds want to end the chaotic digital  wild west with the digital services act  and the digital markets act the digital  world is not the private empire of big  tech it's something that has to work for  everybody every citizen every business  we are all human beings not algorithms  the digital world must become again fair  and transparent with new and exciting  markets and services and innovation  but where citizens know their way  in a trustworthy clear and regulated  world  [Music]